we begin with breaking news out of Egypt
one of our journalists peter gresty has
been freed from prison this is how the
TV channel al-jazeera announced the
release of Peter greste after 400 days
in jail he's finally been allowed to
leave Egypt cresta was arrested along
with two colleagues the head of al
Jazeera's chiro office mohammed bought
me and producer baahar mohammed they
were convicted of spreading lies and
supporting the muslim brotherhood cresta
and POC me were jailed for seven years
Mohammed for 10 listen I still feel the
bitterness and sadness bother me i mean
we and our children have been
overwhelmed by a sense of anguish how
would that above had we felt nothing
else before we've lost our joy had
thought is happening the case sparked an
international outcry critics said Egypt
was sacrificing press freedom as part of
a wider political conflict the Egyptian
authorities accused qatar-based
al-jazeera of being a mouthpiece for the
Muslim Brotherhood the Brotherhood which
is backed by Qatar was banned by Egypt's
military after it overthrew president
Mohamed Morsy in 2013 al-jazeera was
critical of the overthrow and the
crackdown that followed the arrest of
the three journalists further heightened
tensions between Egypt and Qatar but a
breakthrough came after Egypt's appeals
court ordered their retrial president
Abdul Fattah al-sisi also signed a
decree that foreign prisoners could be
deported that laid the legal framework
for peter gresty s release